[Musique]
noël ne sera pas une fait normal cette
année en tout cas notre phrase du jour
est signée olivier ferrand ils n'ont
plus rien à perdre
des commerçants déjà dans le rouge suite
aux premiers confinement prêts à tout
pour sauver leurs affaires je suis mais
scandalisé mais vraiment si jean tenait
un an dans les mains on vit pas dans la
même vie quoi ces gens je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont je sais pas ce qu'il fait
parce qu'ils vivent dans leur quotidien
là ils sont en train de faire mourir
tout un magasin et ma valise avec des
vêtements un pèse-personne ce que j'ai
entamé une grève de la faim depuis c'est
le troisième jour là et j'irai jusque là
où il faut aller pour qu'on m'entende là
haut
non madame nous ne reviendrons pas c'est
certainement pas le moment de revenir
sur les mesures annoncées c'est beaucoup
trop tôt quand les grandes surfaces qui
ont aujourd'hui des rayons consacrés à
la culture par question d'équité avec
les petits commerçants elles ne pourront
pas vendre
il ya d'autres produits qui sont à face
à regarder plus rien et c'est
injustifiable de brendan sont infinies
sottise au lieu de rouvrir les
librairies et d'affirmer l'identité de
la france au lieu de faire ça ils ont eu
une seule idée c'est interdire le livre
partout et de laisser le monopole à
amazon et au e-commerce au troisième
trimestre amazon a vu ses manteaux ses
ventes mondiales progressé de 37% après
un + 40 % les trois mois précédents
l'entreprise a embauché quatre cent
mille personnes dans le monde en 2020 et
tripler son bénéfice
ils peuvent continuer à acheter par
téléphone envoyez un mail à acheter sur
le site internet du commerçant si le
commerçant un site
et puis aller chercher des commandes ou
les mêmes files collecte jeudi aux
françaises et aux français
peut-être que pendant ce mois ci vous
pourriez regarder décalé plutôt que de
commander sur un grand site étranger des
produits pour lutter contre la crise
celle affaire de tous
comment vous même pouvez les expliquer
c'est pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui
alors je
des feux plus convaincant possible je
remarque que tu aimerais avoir réussi à
l'être avec pas encore mais je veux dire
bon courage projet travail de pédagogie
c'est avec deux options que sont sur la
table contrôle et durcissement des
jauges et fermetures des rayons de
produits qui ne sont pas de première
nécessité dans les grandes surfaces la
décision sera arrêtée par le premier
ministre dans la soirée d'ajouter une
disposition qui entrera en vigueur mardi
matin interdisant interdisant la vente
des produits qui ne peuvent pas être
vendus qui sont d'ores et déjà interdite
dans les propres commerces de proximité
d'amples interdisant dans les grandes
surfaces des mers partout en france
elle réclame la réouverture de commerces
de proximité c'est le cas des librairies
ou des salons de coiffure par exemple et
plusieurs élus ont pris des arrêtés
municipaux autorisant ces commerçants à
poursuivre leurs activités
les arrêtés sont illégaux et donc que ça
peut pousser les commerçants à se mettre
en infraction par rapport aux règles
c'est une démission du politique une
fois de plus c'est à dire que d
administrateur lambda qu'on ne connaît
même pas vous dit bruno le maire qui
d'ailleurs par et il adore les livres il
faudrait d'ailleurs écrit mais en
écrivant il en librairie racheter pu s
est produit de maires irresponsables ils
pensent qu'ils soutiennent les
commerçants en réalité ils menacent la
santé des français
je supporte plus ces décisions sont
prises par des gens dont on ne connaît
pas j'imagine mais celle ci gît vous
imaginez c'est à dire le président en
conseil des ministres avec fernandel
enfin su comment il s'appelle joseph
tisseyre que du groupe
je dois vous dire que vous devez compter
sur l'entière détermination du
gouvernement de la république pour
permettre à tous et à chacun de
pratiquer son culte en toute sécurité et
en toute liberté
ce lieu a été détourné de sa vocation
ce lieu a été profané à travers les
trois personnes mortes
vincent nadine simone